[Musica]
se vi chiedessi dove è nata l'unione
europea
cosa mi rispondereste giustamente
qualcuno dice roma o maastricht
eppure l'idea di un'europa unita nasce
soprattutto tra le fila della resistenza
tra la gioventù che si è formata con
l'educazione europea delle bombe dei
massacri del secondo conflitto mondiale
educazione europea è proprio il titolo
di un bellissimo romanzo che racconta la
storia di un gruppo di partigiani
polacchi che usano ironicamente
l'espressione educazione europea per
riflettere su cosa l'europa avesse
insegnato loro questo insegnamento è
condensato nelle parole di janet il
quattordicenne protagonista del racconto
che un certo punto dice che l'europa è
il luogo delle università migliori in
cui si viene da tutto il mondo per
istruirsi ma che alla fine tutto quello
che ti insegna questa famosa educazione
europea e come trovare il coraggio e
delle buone ragioni per ammazzare un
uomo che non ti ha fatto nulla se vi
chiedessi invece a cosa associate l'idea
di un'educazione europea al giorno
d'oggi presumo che la maggioranza
penserebbe subito all'erasmus ecco nel
corso di qualche generazione se inverata
un'europa diversa da quella di jean e
che dei suoi compagni a me colpisce
sempre pensare come per molti giovani
del passato e la guerra sia stata
l'unica forma europea di integrazione
sociale
certo un integrazione forzata
paradossale ispirata al nazionalismo
cioè all'amore per la propria nazione
che si trasformava in odio per le altre
ed è proprio per questo che quella di
unione europea è stata un'idea carica di
immaginazione perché ha permesso di
riscrivere percorsi di integrazione non
solo fra stati
ma soprattutto fra cittadini che fino a
qualche anno prima si erano fatti la
guarda l'unione europea nasce come
progetto di civilizzazione che h
creato uno spazio trasnazionale in cui
sono emerse nuove forme di solidarietà
tra popoli europei è lo strumento
attraverso cui si è fatto tutto questo è
stato il mercato unico
spesso si tende a ridurre l'unione
europea alla sua dimensione strettamente
economica al mercato ma il mercato non è
mai stato davvero un fine in sé ma al
contrario è stato un mezzo se vogliamo
anche simbolico attraverso cui
ridefinire i rapporti fra le nazioni
europee
la cittadinanza europea ha poi
completato questo percorso di
avvicinamento
se infatti col mercato unico solo i
lavoratori potevano spostarsi in altri
stati
grazie alla cittadinanza europea a
chiunque non importa per quali ragioni
può circolare liberamente nel territorio
dell'unione
sentendosi un po meno straniero la
mobilità e quindi la cifra di questa
nuova cittadinanza la libertà di
circolazione la libertà di percorrere
nuove strade e fisiche e metaforiche
oggi che percorreremo insieme
percorreremo un po anche la mia e
scopriremo quelle che ancora devono
essere costruite quanti di voi sono nati
negli anni 80 e 90 alzate la mano come
immaginavo moltissimi probabilmente voi
vi chiederete cosa ci sia di innovativo
in questa cittadinanza
molti di voi me compresa del resto hanno
vissuto magari tutta la loro vita senza
passaporto
abbiamo viaggiato visitato altri stati
con le nostre carte d'identità
stropicciate nella maggior parte dei
casi senza che qualcuno ci controllasse
al confine e senza dover cambiare valuta
brecht diceva con una nota di amarezza
che il passaporto e la parte più nobile
di un uomo e per noi europei baciati
dalla fortuna della geografia ecco per
noi il passaporto sicuramente non lo è
abbiamo costruito le nostre mappe
affettive i nostri ricordi su un
tracciato che non ha più soltanto la
forma di uno stivale il mio primo
ricordo dell'europa ad esempio è legato
alla mia infanzia al matrimonio siculo
inglese dei miei cugini ma penso alle
tante famiglie e relazioni che non hanno
la stessa nazionalità e che vivono in
uno spazio nuovo che non è solo
geografico ma soprattutto emotivo ma
questa nuova spazialità che ci apre i
confini e ci permette di attraversarli
al nostro piacimento non è scontata
tradizionalmente infatti gli stati hanno
il potere discrezionale di decidere chi
ammettere chi escludere sul proprio
territorio
la libertà di circolazione europea
invece è costruita come un vero e
proprio diritto vantato dal cittadino
europeo nei confronti degli stati membri
dell'unione che non possono quindi
rifiutarne l'ingresso la cittadinanza
europea allora non solo si apre una via
mazzo assicura l'arrivo effettivo a
destinazione ma fa di più non si limita
a farci entrare ma ci dà la possibilità
di restare e di stabilire la residenza
nello stato in cui abbiamo deciso di
trasferirci per vivere e lavorare o
studiare i mezzi rosati a questo punto i
più scettici penseranno che questo della
mobilità sia un affare per pochi per chi
può permettersi di andare a caccia di
scommesse opportunità in giro per
l'europa perché provvisto dei mezzi
economici per farlo e invece no
storicamente la cittadinanza europea ha
giovato proprio i lavoratori salariati
non particolarmente qualificati ha
permesso ad esempio ai nostri
connazionali che lavoravano nelle
miniere belghe di migliorare le proprie
condizioni di vita
e questo perché la cittadinanza europea
predica un importante principio che è il
divieto di discriminazione sulla base
della nazionalità e questo principio si
applica anche all'accesso al welfare
nello stato ospitante cioè l'accesso a
tutto quell'insieme di servizi pubblici
prestazioni benefici attraverso cui lo
stato sociale garantisce il benessere
dei suoi cittadini e quindi grazie alle
regole europee a lavoratori stranieri
ero lo stato ospitante deve garantire il
pieno godimento degli stessi diritti
sociali garantiti ai suoi cittadini
la cittadinanza europea allora d'ora
ferma solo la libertà di andare dove si
vuole ma assicura l'uguaglianza e fa
qualcosa di inedito scorporare la
titolarità dei diritti sociali della
nazionalità
cioè i diritti sociali non sono più
appannaggio dei soli la tv ho fatto
l'esempio del lavoratore ma potrei
benissimo fare il mio io mi sono
trasferita il regno unito nel 2016
pagandomi solo il biglietto aereo grazie
al mio status di cittadino europeo ho
beneficiato di una borsa di studio che
mi ha permesso di fare ricerca
al pari dei miei colleghi britannici la
cittadinanza europea allora mi ha dato
una condizione giuridica di uguaglianza
sostanziale è ironicamente anche la
possibilità di fare ricerca sull'unione
europea in uno stato che aveva già
deciso di uscirne il regno unito quindi
non mi è discriminata per la mia
nazionalità e devo ammettere
fortunatamente neanche per il mio
progetto di ricerca ma pensate a quante
opzioni che prima erano privilegio di
pochi oggi sono più alla portata di
tutti la possibilità di perseguire i
propri interessi di scegliere le scuole
accademiche e i programmi che più ci
piacciono e che non necessariamente sono
confinati alla sola dimensione nazionale
la possibilità di studiare in una
università estera senza per questo dover
pagare il doppio delle tasse e usando i
titoli di studio conseguiti nel nostro
paese
pensate ai giovani che trovano lavoro al
termine dei vari tirocini svolti
all'estero
le stime dicono circa il 51 per cento
degli italiani che gli hanno svolti ho
ancora pensato ai pensionati che possono
ritirarsi in qualche paese e assolato
del mediterraneo ma soprattutto pensate
a come la cittadinanza europea potrebbe
cambiare un posto come la sicilia e
spingersi a fare finalmente quel salto
di mentalità spingerci cioè a chiederci
non già cosa possiamo fare per impedire
ai nostri giovani di partire
ma al contrario cosa possiamo fare per
attirarne altri
in tutti questi esempi ho fatto
riferimento soggetti diversi dai
lavoratori
ho parlato di pensionati studenti
giovani in cerca di lavoro perché come
dicevo la cittadinanza europea ha esteso
la libera circolazione a tutti gli
individui compresi quelli che in gergo
vengono definiti con un'espressione
abbastanza brutta e con unitamente
inattivi cioè cittadini che a differenza
dei lavoratori non hanno una chiara
capacità economica c'è però un grosso
limite mentre il diritto di movimento in
sé è riconosciuto a tutti
indistintamente
il diritto di soggiorno degli
economicamente inattivi è condizionato
al possesso di risorse economiche
sufficienti in modo tale che non
diventino un onere per lo stato
ospitante questo requisito dell
autosufficienza economica invece non si
richiede ai lavoratori prima della crisi
in pratica però questa distinzione non
creava grossi problemi ai fini
dell'attribuzione dei benefici sociali
ai cittadini economicamente inattivi
perché gli stati tendevano a non
verificare il soddisfacimento di questo
requisito dell'autosufficienza e ne è un
esempio la mia borsa di studio io non ho
dovuto provare alcunchè per ottenerla
con la crisi economica in mezzo il suo
il rischio concreto che gli stati
possano cominciare a far leva su questo
limite per escludere alcuni cittadini
europei dai benefici sociali
la crisi economica quindi il resto
evidente un paradosso che è sempre
esistito nelle regole europee
quello per cui l'assistenza sociale
nello stato ospitante può essere
richiesta soltanto dai cittadini europei
inattivi che siano autosufficienti ma
che per definizione se sono
autosufficienti non avranno bisogno di
assistenza sociale e mezzo allora la
necessità di riscrivere queste regole
europee e di superare questo corto
circuito generato dall autosufficienza
economica e ci sono almeno due argomenti
che ci impongono di farlo il primo è un
argomento di uguaglianza politica la
cittadinanza europea è stata istituita
al fine di rendere l'unione un progetto
più
esclusivo oggi invece rischia di creare
delle discriminazioni e di escludere
dalla libera circolazione
una fetta della popolazione quella senza
lavoro che paradossalmente ne avrebbe
più bisogno
c'è poi un altro argomento di ordine
logico la distinzione fra economicamente
attivi e quindi lavoratori e inattivi è
diventata quasi insensata al fine di
stabilire chi è destinato a pesare sul
welfare dello stato ospitante
visti i cambiamenti che hanno investito
il mondo del lavoro
leicester e lavoratori oggi non equivale
automaticamente a disporre di risorse
economiche sufficienti visto il numero
crescente dei cosiddetti working poor
dei precari dei part time che non
guadagnano abbastanza e soprattutto
questa distinzione fra attivi e inattivi
non tiene conto di quei soggetti che
svolgono una serie di attività come ad
esempio le attività di cura o alcune
attività intellettuali che non sono
retribuite e che quindi non esistono per
le statistiche ufficiali
occorre allora ripensare la cittadinanza
europea in quanto legata ad un modello
ormai superato dalla storia delle
relazioni produttive quella del
lavoratore subordinato a tempo pieno e
indeterminato e occorre ripensarle in
funzione della nuova composizione
sociale del lavoro che penso di
rispecchiare perfettamente migrante
femminile con italia ci sono tanti
cittadini sulla carta inattivi che pure
danno un contributo alla comunità
ospitante contributo che non è sempre
monetizzabile o monetizzato questi
cittadini fanno ormai parte di quella
comunità da qui sarebbe pertanto
ingiusto sradicargli penso alle donne
che svolgono lavoro domestico non
retribuito e che a causa di questa
stretta sulle prestazioni sociali non
avrebbero più accesso a strumenti di
emancipazione ma penso più banalmente
anche alla mia storia personale
io in questo momento mi ritrovo ad avere
più legami con l'academy inglese
rispetto a quella italiana e quindi da
precaria spererei di non essere
discriminata per la mia nazionalità se
volesse accedere ad un'altra borsa di
studio ci serve allora una nuova
educazione europea
che scongiuri il rifiorire dei
nazionalismi e ci insegna a superare una
concezione in archivistica del welfare
che vede cioè lo stato sociale con una
sfera chiusa impenetrabile possa
protezione dei soli nazionali
occorre invece recuperare la funzione
originaria del welfare la sua vocazione
autentica è quella di risolvere le
disuguaglianze non discriminare fra chi
è nazionale e chi non lo è il ritorno ad
un welfare chiuso su base nazionale la
fine della libera circolazione
a me pare essere il sintomo di un
attaccamento nostalgico ad un mondo che
non esiste più è il rigurgito
identitario legato al mito della nazione
intesa come comunità immutabile questa
chiusura non può essere la soluzione
tanti individui appartengono di fatto ad
una comunità politica diversa da quella
a cui sono stati ascritti alla nascita
in virtù dell arbitrio del caso
la nazione è una categoria affettiva che
non può diventare la guida della nostra
azione politica ed è forse proprio vero
che si comincia a parlare di identità
quando si smette di parlare di ciò che
si ha in comune e io credo che occorra
ragionare su cosa abbiamo in comune con
chi vive nel nostro stesso spazio per
costruire delle forme di solidarietà
orizzontale cioè delle forme di
solidarietà tra noi individui che sono
poi quelle che stanno alla base della
giustizia sociale della redistribuzione
attuata tramite i meccanismi di welfare
ci servono nuove forme di solidarietà
non più basate sulla nazionalità ma su
una comune condizione socio economica
cominciamo a pensare a delle soluzioni
che siano europee a problemi che sono
già trasnazionali e per farlo c'è
bisogno dell'impegno di tutti
siamo ormai cittadini d'europa ed è
tempo che l'europa diventi dei cittadini
per quanto retorica ed inflazionata
questa frase possa suonare però è
proprio vero che è nell'europa e non più
nelle piccole comunità nazionali che si
iscrivono i percorsi del futuro che sono
percorsi per tutti e di tutti perché la
mobilità europea su ha consegnato
l'intreccio di tante biografie che si
svolgono al di fuori dei confini
nazionali
e queste vite ci dicono che per usare le
parole di janet l'europa ha già
cominciato ad ergersi e camminare
attraverso di loro grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]